oh boy soon i'm graeme an area very well
thank you thank you mr. Glover we're
arriving in Adelaide after our flight
was delayed
how many epic hotel rooms could put us
in for god sakes
why is it like that [ __ ] litter looks so
cool and Adalind keep on surprise of
that shake
quick game escape
who goes first
the time
l'chaim brother
English hamish day that was [ __ ] so
much fun yeah dude we wrote it we wrote
it and governing in look man like guys
by fairly my barrel is what's your name
look at my dates page hey in a riot of
my own right I mean this arm is kind of
a mess I don't mind beating hey you know
what that looks [ __ ] good let's get
the [ __ ] out of here and go to Sydney
attention ha ha
yeah what's up dude I love people with
the initiative to be backstage already
at the venue party oh yeah how long you
guys been camped out here for well for
hours big fans I appreciate that man
[ __ ] yeah what's wrong with this tattoo
tooth is wrong but let you'll get the
wrong tooth yeah which one's its first
to be that third one yeah you [ __ ] good
deal bro get the [ __ ] third it's not
keep me
what do you got for birth and I was just
thinking I don't really how Cindy Lauper
thank you sir welcome aboard today hey
there Scott Randolph with the Michael
Jackson up kick
I didn't even understand how crazy the
cigarette situation is you gotta see
these packs let's look back you know
that is Marlboro red
hey you're the best man thanks
oh my god
laughs I'm sure and actually it's not
because I'm flying to New Zealand about
an hour
you damn shirt on lot of this what
happens in New Zealand so subscribe here
and remember balls and the age the show
I look at it